what's up guys lunch money time
while wall street's trying to get rich
the rest of us just trying to get our
lunch money right
bang bang let's get this money
don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five get money get
paid you just stole that from me like
nobody's business
it's fine i'm here with the gorgeous and
intelligent planet marinova today she's
got a shirt on she looks like she's in
motley crew
like we're just gonna go rock out and to
bring the guns out
guns out motley crew time what's up
block five three products
you deposit crypto they give you a us
dollar loan you can buy and sell crypto
or
my favorite product i'm an investor a
user a fan
a cheerleader is you can deposit and
earn up to eight point six percent in an
interest bearing account go in the
description click the link
tell them that you saw it here we're
cool they'll give you free [ __ ]
it's awesome what's going on with
starbucks
starbucks not an ad not an ad
says you see how i'm keeping it here so
i don't spill it again like last time
oh we know the carpet has had a lot of
trouble recently my fat ass stepping on
it her spilling coffee on it it's fine
starbucks says it lost three billion
dollars in revenue
in the latest quarter due to coronavirus
so we weren't able to lift them up
boost them up well is it uh
they lost three billion dollars or they
didn't
make three billion dollars it's
predicting it
lost as much as 3.2 billion in revenue
yeah
that's pretty bad but but again i don't
i don't
understand if it's a loss like they
actually
spent three billion dollars that they
didn't make or if the revenue is down
the revenue is down yeah revenue is down
see this is the little wall street
tricks
it's all right pumps looking out for you
guys spent
they said they lost i know but losing
three billion dollars of revenue meant
that
hey last year at this time we made six
billion this year we're only gonna make
three billion
you technically didn't lose money you
just didn't make as much money as you
wanted to make
versus if you actually lost the money
meaning hey
we spent six billion dollars but we only
made three that means we literally
lost three billion just a small aside if
you're ever in an argument with him
he will use all the semantics and say
that's not exactly the word so that
that's where this is coming from but i
appreciate you
okay hey um you know what words matter
how come
words matter how come starbucks isn't
complaining about it i feel like
everybody we've heard from everyone
it's because it's starbucks right like
again here's the whole thing is
starbucks actually is really interesting
early on uh they were one of the first
data points i saw
uh to give a sense of how china was
recovering
so uh starbucks is global business right
they've got um locations everywhere
and uh they were one of the first
companies
in the us that have a big u.s presence
to say hey we're shutting down our
stores in china
so that was kind of like oh that's kind
of interesting that starbucks is
shutting down
and then when they came back they
started to say as the us was kind of
shutting down stores
the chinese stores were coming back and
so they were able to kind of balance
they didn't have to shut down globally
everywhere all at once
um so it's kind of interesting just to
see like these global businesses if
you're sitting there
uh i think most people have a very
western-centric uh
view of the world because that's where
their business is starbucks is much more
global and they've got to kind of
pay attention across the world hold on
before we get into this
we need to address something very
serious that happened yesterday
in the comment section oh hey listen you
guys gotta chill out
i can count to 80. just so everyone's
clear i saw all the comments i read
every single one of them
the turnings there's four of them
they're 20 years apiece
what i was trying to say but i'm dumb so
i didn't say it correctly
is that 2020 is the start
of the fourth 20 years that leads to the
80 year the completion of the full 80
year cycle
i know that 1960 to 2020
is not 80 years in 60 years but this is
the start of the fourth one
which gets us to the full 80 year cycle
so don't unsubscribe
he can count yeah i can count one two
six
five it's all the same whatever my
favorite my favorite thing to say to
people is there's a one plus one equals
three or four scenario
they all kind of hate that that is such
a silicon valley crap that i can't stand
it
okay let's move on virtual road show
don't make me
get the guns out if you were a motley
crew would you paint your face
i haven't seen it oh we could watch the
next i don't want to
sex drugs and rock and roll baby
all right what's going on the virtual
road show virtual road show so
first of all do you want to explain what
an ipo road show is it's basically a
marketing
campaign yeah you basically go convince
everyone your company's better than it
really is
invite and try to convince them to
invest by everyone you mean
uh rich people and bankers yeah exactly
private family offices
big banks anyone who's got a lot of
money like we're talking you know
billions of dollars
you basically go and you meet with them
you give a presentation you say hey
here's what our business does here's why
it's a great business you should invest
in it here's where we think we're going
in the future
all the things it's a fundraising uh
kind of trip
marketing but you just it's called a
road show because you literally go to
like
50 of them all within uh 30 days or
something right
so what's going on there so apparently
now because of coronavirus
some companies are considering doing
virtual road shows which
basically like well they've been doing
virtual once during
coronavirus during the pandemic they've
had to do virtual road shows
right but it's um i mean obviously it's
just like a
online um presentation why wouldn't you
do a virtual road show yeah hey
i'm team remote work why do you gotta
travel anywhere who cares by the way
american airlines shout out to you guys
he traveled so much last year
i i forgot 120 flights baby
but i actually don't like doing it it's
annoying so now that everyone else is
used to doing these
um uh virtual meetings and
and remote work i think that people can
get away with never travel it's gonna be
awesome
but see look at what one uh one founder
says
um they're worried that you know if they
can't meet in person they won't be able
to get
the kind of engagement they want from
people and face-to-face interactions are
useful in building trust with investors
particularly when they're deciding
whether to invest loser mentality
if you got a good enough company they'll
invest if you want to build more trust
build a better business it's that simple
look people could look at a spreadsheet
they don't even have to talk to the
founders you could literally look at a
spreadsheet no is it a good business and
i want to own a piece or i don't want to
own a piece
talking to the founder is additive to
that you're saying that the road shows
in general are just kind of like a
fluffy just i don't think that they're
necessarily fluffy
uh i think that they're a very important
part of if you want to go public
uh part of the public market beauty is
that their scrutiny right like the
scrutiny in the
uh public markets is much more than the
private markets and so you have
professional investors who sit and they
ask you questions about your business
it's valuable to the founder i think
because it makes them think more
critically about their business
but also too is it's a valuable process
and if you want people to put hundreds
of millions of dollars if not billions
of dollars in your company
you got to convince them to do it so
it's not just the formality that you
have to go through before going public
but do you remember i believe it was
slack who did not do
a road show because they had that um
non-traditional ipo they went uh public
via direct listing
yeah so basically if you're not trying
to raise money in the ipo
process then you don't need to do the
road show right because you're not
trying to convince anyone to invest so
there you go
yes so if you do the direct listings for
sure the other thing is uh if you look
at like what chamoth is doing with
um the spax you also don't need to do a
road show in that situation
if you're the founder because basically
the spac the special
uh purpose acquisition company uh it
just acquires your business
right into it now chamoth and adam bain
and kind of all of the people involved
in the spec
they have to go do a road show to raise
the capital right okay
do you remember when spotify and slack
uh
went public via um direct listing and
then airbnb
was claiming that it was going to do a
direct listing to go public yes
do you think that in the time of post
covad
this will become more of a trend uh i
don't think that covet has as much to do
with direct listing versus traditional
ipo i think that just the structure of
the market is
broken uh bill gurley has been all over
this from very early on
and the whole idea is uh the incentives
are off so if i'm the founder
my goal should be to raise as much money
as possible for his least amount of my
business
so if i can raise a hundred million
dollars for 10 percent i should try to
do that
but the bankers what they want to happen
is they want their investors to buy
equity in a business and then success of
the ipo is judged
based on when the company goes public
does the stock price go up or not
but if you think of it from the
founder's perspective wait a second i
just sold you guys a part of my business
and then when it got in the public
market it went up in price yeah that
means that i sold it to you for less
than it was worth
right right right right so the so the
the incentives are awesome
yeah the bankers want the pop the
investors want the pop but that means
the founders didn't get as much money as
they should have got they're like
leaving money on the table
um smaller side
[Laughter]
yesterday and there was a really funny
uh video i saw of this girl it was
um the shark tank music and she was
walking into her house and it said
about to go ask my dad for five thousand
dollars with zero percent equity
no okay all right what's going on amazon
credit oh man jeff bezos
okay so small business owners who sell
on amazon's platform we'll soon be
receiving invitations from goldman sachs
uh for revolving credit lines with a
fixed annual interest rate of 6.99
percent to 20.99
so amazon and goldman are teaming up to
provide credit lines for small business
owners
on amazon it's a no-brainer we've seen
this in other platforms there's all
kinds of businesses that are doing it
i've invested in businesses that are
doing this for
subsets of the market i've got friends
who are investors and businesses that
are doing this
okay the whole idea is uh if you have
access to the data
right then you can underwrite the
business that there's a new type of
lending available
uh it doesn't surprise me that amazon
wants to get in this game it can be
incredibly profitable
especially when you're charging seven to
twenty percent interest
rates uh and so look some small
businesses will use it some won't
okay but can i just say goldman sachs
which was once referred to
as a giant evil squid with its tentacles
like trying to suffocate
businesses and people and whatever is
now we are willing to trust it
with all of our data yeah but every
bank's like that
it's just that goldman said about
goldman but they're all like that okay
but
why but okay if you're a small business
though you're not necessarily trusting
goldman with it you trusted amazon with
it but it's not your data in that
situation
right like that this is the beauty of
these vertically integrated businesses
is
amazon has the data you they give you
data that is theirs but they actually
own the customer
they own the they own the purchase data
they own all of the targeting like
it's their platform you have to if you
do apply for this you have to consent
to give up your data so just fyi so you
they probably
say something just to really cover their
ass but at the end of the day
amazon has the data right and what
you're doing is you're consenting for
amazon to give it the goal do we think
that amazon's just going to take over
everything
no is is it gonna touch every aspect of
our lives
uh jeff bezos would like it to happen
but but you have to remember also that
like
jeff bezos and amazon they are out
executing people this is not a game
where like uh if you look at airlines
for example
it's really hard to start a new airline
and the
incumbents enjoy a position where they
can provide
shitty service and just no competition
comes into the market that's not what
happens with amazon amazon actually has
the best product in many many
cases um in most cases and this is also
on the other side helping goldman
because
it wanted to it's really trying to get
into the small business market
as of late yeah of course i mean look
goldman is
uh we may not like them right or or
people may like them
but they're incredibly intelligent you
can't argue that they're not smart uh
and this is a no-brainer get into a
business of
offering credit to a demographic of
businesses that you previously couldn't
reach
and their ceo is a dj yeah what up dj
soul
i hear you all right what's going on
with the election mess
all right every election is a mess all
the politicians are the same wearing a
georgia shirt
because in georgia okay we're not doing
that go ahead
um so yesterday people went out to vote
in the primaries
and georgia has this new 100 million
dollar plus
voting system that it installed
there um it did not work well so
there were long lines uh now there's
investigations into it
my favorite line in this article is um
uh okay uh counting
county officials blamed state officials
who blamed poll workers who blamed the
machines
i got a hot take what's up i don't trust
any of the election software
okay i mean it's old no no just even the
new stuff
wait why because i don't believe that
there's enough
people who understand technology
who are actually auditing these systems
and are unbiased
in ensuring that they are actually valid
there's
every election there's issues i i agree
um do you think that the government uses
like private tech companies to help them
with their
building this stuff of course well okay
so it's a it's a 100 million dollar
voting system we the government paid
themselves i don't know but let me just
tell you
um new york city was like we're going to
create this new beautiful system called
project
cupid for marriage virtual marriage
licenses i mean it was a complete
disaster if you're
if somebody from there is watching they
did it over microsoft teams
the whole point is no no no no the
actual system oh the whole point is just
like look
uh this election software's super
important there's been a million debates
against politicize all this problem at
the end of the day this is
a mission critical software for
democracy and you're outsourcing it to
usually private companies to create the
software um and there's just so many
things that could go wrong
and so many people in the process don't
actually have the technical skills
to be able to understand if something
went wrong and like here's to what i
always tell people
when you punch in whatever it is on the
voting thing
a lot of times you'll get a receipt
right it'll say hey here's what you
voted for or whatever
but then once it goes how how do you
know that it actually got recorded that
way okay i'm sorry
but this should be completely
super simple uh systems in place here
because you're literally just voting for
a person
another person another person and that's
it that's it that's all they have to do
it's like a survey but but here's the
hard part is you're taking on the
platform risk of or the third party risk
of whoever's processing that information
so like what's the process with the
concern it's not hard
the concern is that you go and let's say
you hit on a kiosk
and you say i'm voting for candidate a
for president
candidate b for vice president well by
from you touching that button to the
time it gets written in the database
how do you know it didn't get switched
to somebody else how would it get
switched it's because there's a
nefarious actor somebody is trying to
throw the election
right somebody's trying to change the
information then how do you know that
once it's written in the database then
you have to go
count right and then there's things like
well what district are you actually in
because if you remember
in the united states it's not just about
the general population uh
majority like if you win the general
population there's the electoral college
so there's all these complexities to it
but here's the here's the uh the crazy
part the us is actually one of the best
systems in the world
like in the middle east i think in
afghanistan uh at one point
you would go vote and literally when you
would vote you would dip your finger in
ink and so that they knew that you had
already voted so you couldn't vote a
second time
but then what would happen is like
people like the taliban would be like oh
you got ink on your finger you went and
voted in the democracy we're gonna kill
you oh my god
crazy role world wait uh doesn't bradley
tusk promote something that's like
blockchain voting
uh yeah tusk uh so for those that don't
know bradley tusk previously uh worked
with mike bloomberg in the new york uh
city mayor's office
um i really like bradley i think plane
likes him as well uh i had him on the
podcast
and um he was a big proponent of
blockchain
based i thought that was interesting
mainly because you can ensure that it's
immutable so now we can change it right
talk about the problem i just uh
discussed and also you can go check it
so like you know what it actually got
uh booked as um look they've tested a
couple times i think west virginia
tested it for like soldiers who weren't
there they could try it all that kind of
stuff
uh eventually we will have better
technology solutions just right now
you know georgia spent a hundred million
dollars on a system that seems to not
have work so hot so
like how do you do that by the way 100
million is cheap
oh jesus imagine that pitch hey by the
way we're going to ensure democracy in
your state
uh how much is that going to cost how
much money you got your budget well i
hope
i hope they get a refund because
obviously it didn't help democracy
what's going on with nypd complications
what's going on with the boys in blue
complicated what's going on the boys in
blue the thin blue line
i got all kinds of names for them i'll
stated the nice ones
oh my god yesterday we saw a cop do a
not so nice thing but anyway
so the the head of the union you did see
that
the head of the new york police union is
railing against
legislators media and everyone for
vilifying
law enforcement i mean okay so i watch
that video
i kind of like i kind of understand
who's the guy michael mara who is the
new york
police oh like a union president
he's a cop and he represents all the
police officers so that's his job
yes and he gave his really impassioned
speech
my two problems with this or one
at one point he literally says like
we're demanding respect
you have to respect us right great that
sounds awesome when you're giving a
locker room speech to your troops
the problem is that's not how respect
works you don't get to demand
respect you earn respect and so step one
is stop demanding it and go out and earn
the respect
that's first of all by the way i
actually think most police officers are
really great people and they're trying
to do the right thing
the second problem i have is he's acting
like there's not videos all over the
internet of nypd
literally beating unarmed citizens and
nypd cop just got
uh i think he got charged with felony
assault
it was it yes there's a cop in new york
city who
was walking down the street and a woman
a protester unarmed was saying something
to him
and he went at her and then shoved her
to the ground and she hit her head
uh back on the pavement and he said some
not so nice words i think cursed at her
too
and now he's charged with felony assault
well good he should be so weavers but
here's the thing is
should should this guy maybe he should
instead have a different message which
is hey
we don't always get it right and we're
actually going to clean up our ranks
and we're going to earn your respect
because that would have a
much different reception from people
than you must respect us look at my
badge you must respect right right it
was a very kind of tone-deaf thing
but i will and there was all white cops
standing behind him oh i didn't notice
that yeah from from the video didn't
look like there was any minority cop
standing in the phone i i
will say though it's very hard like um
when i was in the media and when i would
hear people being like oh the media
they're all just trying to screw us and
they get together and they have this
like that doesn't happen in in worse
they're all biased no and i know that
there's like people who do bad things
and
you know they plagiarize all this kind
of stuff they're not ethical
but because i'm not one of those people
it felt really personal
and i was mad et cetera and i think that
that's a little bit how these people
feel
again there is the the thing that the
internet has done
is the internet has shined a light into
a world that most people never get to
see
right because most people don't live in
the communities that are over policed
and things like that
and now all of a sudden this cell phone
gives everyone
a picture into that world and what we're
realizing is
wait a minute the way that the police
officer treats me
meaning me personally is not the same
way that they treat other people
and it is not every single cop
that is doing bad things again most cops
are good people most cops
literally want to protect and serve
their communities but the two things
that end up
happening is one you get power trips
literally they just
they just go and do things they would
never do outside of unity we saw
yesterday
so the incident we saw yesterday we were
literally walking down the street in
midtown manhattan
this is it i mean this is in the middle
of manhattan and uh
a cop is parked at a red light he's
pulled up to a red light there's two
cops driver under passengers
there's an old man in a car next to them
and
the old man is looking he's got his
window rolled down and he's looking
at the cops i don't think he did he have
his window yeah he he had his passenger
window
maybe he was saying something we didn't
hear him say anything
but all of a sudden the cop in the
passenger seat
leans over and yells out the window and
goes what do you want jerk off
and it's like look is that really is
that illegal no
is that cop an [ __ ] i don't know i
don't know that cop i don't know what
happened before or whatever
but at the end of the day what ends up
occurring is
and incident after incident after
incident after incident you get in a
situation where people start to say
hey the police officer is held to a
higher standard
than the citizens because the police
officer has a badge they have training
that is their job
and therefore even if people do all
kinds of
rude inappropriate things as a police
officer
you have to maintain your core right
right and so when you start to call
the citizens that you're there to
protect and search for jerk offs yeah
again it's not illegal you can do it you
can say whatever you want and also it's
just not a good look i think encounters
like that
show us that in a lot of uh altercations
it goes bad when the police officer
loses their cool
of course and gets nervous gets scared
but is that
not that that means he was not properly
trained well well or or just people
don't have discipline again these people
are human right like
i actually look i've literally been in a
uniform before with a gun like i get it
right and by the way there's also videos
of people
being [ __ ] to the cops like i saw a
video the other day where
there's a guy who walks up to a whole
bunch of police officers lined up on the
streets in new york
and he looks at and finds the shortest
guy and he starts going off on him right
he's like dude
whoop your ass right now like you're a
little [ __ ] you know literally you
should go get in the weight room like i
whoop your eyes you're lucky all your
friends are here
whatever and he's got a camera a family
show and he's got a camera but what he's
trying to do is he's trying to basically
take advantage of the fact that he knows
the cops aren't going to do anything
i know right which by the way makes that
guy an [ __ ] and so it's just the
situation where like
we could all benefit from kindness
and understanding that like we're in
this together yeah but that's not just
the citizens treating the cops that way
right so the citizens shouldn't respect
the cops
but the cops have to understand you earn
that respect you can't demand the
respect
and when you go on television and you're
literally got your badge and you're
yelling and screaming
is it kind of amazing though that
america is pretty much the only country
you can do that in any other country you
go up to cops and you start doing that
good luck but here's the thing right and
this is something that i personally feel
really strongly about
is part of the beauty of america is the
checks and balances remember the
government
does not control us they're not supposed
to they try to but they're not supposed
to
instead the government there is there to
serve at our pleasure right so the
police officers
we pay for the police officers right
right they're technically on the
taxpayers payroll
and so we forget all of that because
they have a monopoly on violence and
kind of all of this different stuff
i think what we're seeing through all of
these protests is
there's a conversation now right and
again there needs to be reform but this
is a perfect example of
the police union's power is they went
got a bunch of cops stand up in the line
got on television and are yelling and
screaming about how they must be
demanded or
they're demanding respect and it's just
like look guys
that world's gone like you don't get to
do that anymore now we're in a world
where
actually the person with the cell phone
has just as much power as the police
if not more power because now we're
seeing police officers actually be
charged
right we saw officers in buffalo get
charged we saw officers in new york city
get charged
they're going to start getting charged
with the things that they're doing
and it's going to make them all question
hey the action i'm about to take
is this appropriate which actually is
probably a net positive but
hey by the way they're still good cops
last thing i'll say is um
we talked to my dad this weekend and he
uh
he he grew up in communist bulgaria and
he was part of the riots and the
protests and whatever against the
oppressive government as he saw it um
and
he what did he say this week weekend he
was like isn't that scary how like
your freedoms can be gone like that yeah
he just in a
he didn't say these words but he
basically was hinting at the fact
of like i've seen this playbook before
right like i've seen like the end of
this play
uh and it doesn't end well in terms of
if communism and socialism and all that
stuff gets implemented
uh it's just really bad and so you know
look again
uh here's the one part that always gets
left out of the conversation so i want
to make sure i say this
every single police officer that i know
personally right guys i served in the
military with or police officers that i
know
they all have the same goal they want to
go to work they want to do their job
and they want to go home safely at night
to their families that's it
just like every other person wants to go
to their job etc what happens between
the time they leave their home
and they come back to their home that's
what is in question now
but generally i think 99.9
of cops are good people it's just about
they're just in a system
that could be broken it's just about
seeing people's humanity and i think
the cops should do that and the people
protesting the cops should do that and
regular people should do that
would you go out in the protest
um i can i think she's thinking
this is this we talked about this
yesterday because i think every person
can use their social capital and
influence to create meaningful change
and
the only way is not to go march
maybe that is for you but i think like
we can create
meaningful change by talking about this
stuff and you know
just having a good conversation what's
going on with cristiano ronaldo
okay he is officially the first
footballer to bank one billion dollars
that puts him
not real football that this is uh soccer
that they used
football football american football
kidding
i'm kidding i'm kidding so ronaldo joins
tiger woods and floyd mayweather
as the third active athlete to surpass a
billion dollars
but this is in career earnings and i
believe
is this from just contracts or does this
include sponsorship money i don't know
it does it not tell us so ronaldo's 105
million earnings took him to number four
on the celebrity 100 list one spot ahead
of rival
lee lenol messi leoni
oh my god i don't know that's not an
american name
lionel lionel like lionel richie
that doesn't sound like an american
person um roger
federer kanye west why is kanye west and
kylie jenner
on the list of athletes i don't know
he's the most followed athlete on social
media ronaldo uh he's got around 200
million followers on instagram which is
massive uh and in addition to joining
tiger woods and mayweather jr
ronaldo is the first active athlete to
hit the landmark playing in a team sport
which is really interesting
so most of the other athletes tiger
woods and floyd mayweather
individuals individuals he's playing a
team sport billion dollars
17 seasons as a professional soccer
player so
um okay wait one more thing i know we're
out of time but yesterday he called me
not athletic and then i went and i beat
him at chess
and a bad game holla at me
she did beat me yesterday at chess and
back game at back to back
i had a uh a situation i i almost went
mental
it was bad i didn't even i like i felt
the chess game
i'm not gonna say she cheated because
she didn't cheat i did not
as cl as close to the line between luck
and cheating as you can get plano was
straddling that line why did i cheat
you're gonna lie like that right now
you're gonna yeah you know
she was she was doing some i was it was
a skill
okay we'll see he's so salty i'm still
mad
about it that's great all right guys
carpet's safe plina's happy
we're going to just create our own
motley crew we'll see you guys tomorrow
lunch money well wall street's trying to
get rich with us let's just trying to
get our lunch money right
oh
bang bang hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block 5 so go check them
out there's a link in the description
that you can click on
i'm an investor a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block fly's my second favorite thing in
the world behind polina they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to eight point six percent
interest on an interest
account or you can buy and sell
cryptocurrencies on their crypto
exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find
up to 8.6 interest on a deposit in an
interest bearing account
go do your own research there's risks
associated but 8.6
is pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends